hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
I'm here with ro and today what are we
doing do you know what we're doing I
love that you brought all this stuff
over because I love getting into the
spirit of the holidays I even wore my
holiday sweater for you this is really
cute and I'm wearing your holiday
diamond antlers yeah I found that
Nordstrom it was really cute and I was
like really good it's great thank you
well today we're doing something very
interesting and I don't even know if
this is gonna work to be honest with you
like most of my videos I know I was like
I think I'm really fun if we tried to do
a blindfold tree decorating challenge
hmm so give me blindfold yeah but I
think we should probably put the tree
together because there's a little bit of
a problem when you shop online things
tend to look a little bit smaller well
this is the tree that I got it was oh my
gosh I thought a foot and is not a foot
no and I think that we have to put it
together so and I honestly don't know
how tall this is I wanted some sort of
like pre-lit garland to put on the tree
business whoa this is not it looks like
a log oh this is something that you
would just put on your mantle this kind
of looks as big as the tree but we can
see I have to set this aside thank you
so the blindfolds are a little way out
it looks just in if you put it on Maddie
it peed looks like a little later look
at him if you want ma ma everything here
a little Liam oh wow that's a smelly now
so we should probably put the tree
together okay okay all right I don't
know if I can put that together
blindfold I'm unsure if we'll be able to
use our four eyes and put the secret but
this is half of it just thing this is me
maybe actually I think it is mrs. Hughes
maybe we could just put together half of
it well that's just gonna look like a
shrub I mean I'm okay with that if you
are I'm invested now Justine this is
gonna happen so we're not decorating a
shrub happy holidays
girl and I head up at your house with a
shrimp and I'm like wasn't that great a
shrub I would be totally fine with that
and really yes so things are going well
over here how are you well I'm just
Fanning these out
okay are you getting pinched no you
don't need it okay I don't know how that
got in my mouth
could you imagine if that was our job we
just for the holidays went around to all
of our friends house and brought
memories I love it hey guys it's ro and
dusty and we brought you a holiday tree
I'd say the first one we should go to we
should go to Joey's house you didn't
like a tree we picked out for him he
would love it hey maybe we just give him
this one it'll be in the dumpster yeah
careful I don't want you to get pinched
oh cool
amazing I think it looks just you know
it's okay it's not the best but it's not
the worst okay how it all is it even is
Vegas me actually
oh well most okay so we need to raise it
a little bit okay our tree is all set up
and ready to go we've got these
decorations I mean this looks like an
absolute just mess like we went and
raided like the the discount bin and
everything else it's leftover after
Christmas is like here you go
okay let's put easel blindfold bottle
Maddie masks okay you we just start I
don't know or mine on wait let me see
and I want to feel you where are you I'm
here okay oh yeah that's it alrighty we
can't cheat the first thing I'm touching
her life yes we got a string the light I
think we should do lights first yeah
okay can you help me yes okay so I
remember the end is let me feel it
wait do I have with something this is a
plug you had the end I've got an end
okay you're supposed to start at the top
or the bottom I'm thinking of Drake and
he started from the bottom and now he's
here which is the top well how do i plug
it in on the top that's that's a great
point so you start at the top of your
end because I've got the plug-in end
look you're in the bottom on the bottom
you're in the bottom yes I your where
where's the bottom know what I have the
bottom so you mean we'll hand it to me
top now here take this because I'm
taller yeah cuz you Tyler singing drink
okay to see you start from the bottom
right here create the top of the tree no
it will never happen
wait why is this so heavy get this off
what is this
I'm trying to find the end of this thing
it isn't like an eternity there's
something wait do you still have the end
yeah okay good
wait something's touching me yeah
there's something mommy I thought I had
this in a seaweed or something okay
stuck to this alright cuz we got no okay
oh yeah try knocked over is this thin
nice sandy I can appeal it alright I got
the top so what I'm gonna do is I
probably wouldn't suggest doing this but
I'm gonna just tie this at the top
perfect
okay then we know it can't go anywhere
so it won't lose okay alright I'm gonna
put this around the tree okay right I
don't know I I feel sideways let me see
I just don't remember how big the tree
is hand it over here the lights in there
so that looks natural
I don't know where the other end line in
here
wait a minute come on please I'm
completely lost it wait wait where's
your hands my hands are here so we're
here that's my elbow this is my hand
okay and okay here's your string it's in
my hand here I'm not sure it's stuck
somewhere you've got a plug in
oh shoot but where's the rest of it no
this was a short one huh are you sure
there's no other I don't have any more
you're positive
yeah where did it go well I guess we've
got our lights on okay wait check I feel
some garland oh here you go
this feels like it's beautiful like this
works nice got something you stuck on my
leg oh I got another piece of Garland
it's cutting me okay I would just put
this around in the middle and I'm gonna
do this by doing a big hug three I don't
know what you're doing but it sounds
amazing
I'm gonna put this at the top like a
star I forgot to get a tree topper okay
I've got these icicles mm-hmm these are
really tangled though those are really
cool
I think you should put them on okay now
I'm gonna find I know we have ornaments
around you did this is a pen oops sorry
these are a do-it-yourself what's this
this one was to a stick effect on me I
feel so dizzy so I can hear him when I
was looking at these earlier when I was
having yeah had hooks but I don't think
we can that's gonna be too much of it
difficult pass hooks on because we like
I can feel these yes nice Oh
let's put some balls on here okay I'll
do the ones at the bottom okay I'll take
guys a tongue short we are hitting
everything that a tree means yes we've
got my stencil here mints we got
something on the top of the tree and
we're giving it a lot of love which is
very very important
well what about back here that's the
other
justine when people are decorating trees
they always forget about the back of the
tree this is a 363 the Front's all
decorated and then the backs all naked
not yourselves I'm going to decorate the
back okay I'm gonna try to make a star
for the top I'm hoping this is yellow
but I am not sure about the color I'm
gonna do some DIY ornaments you are I'm
gonna try it see I think this is gonna
be a just at least one okay are you
doing a ball or a paper I'm willing to
put a paper in the ball Wow
like crumbles it up okay I'm gonna try
okay now I know there's hooks here oh my
bottom I'm gonna lock my ball oh here
here's a hook I'm gonna draw something
on here okay
oh my god we have a pen where'd that
hook though there is I'm whether my
mouth or near here we go here we go
here's your pen I think it might be
careful that's gonna be it
this is wet so Justine yeah I ornament
has to dry okay just be really careful
our I'll keep that in mind okay so just
be careful so what's on this one I did
it gingerbread man oh oh it's Nick maybe
like a reindeer are we out of things to
put on the tree and then I'm gonna draw
a head and that's it thank you there's
so much closer when I need five balls
look hope you can't see I can't see
either we feel we give me your hand
where we got this oh we've got to put it
yeah three okay we gotta find the end
okay okay I have the plug in I got it
well you know what I thought I could
plug this into the top of the tree
because it had that extension cord you
think you could well we're gonna see
yeah I love my oh wait here's my car
later but over here where the heck is
that end I don't want to
it's great you can give me find it I
don't think I did okay I have cat-like
reflexes
I guess is just decorate now we just
throw this yo I gots wrong I got the UM
you know I got the top end yeah so you
can switch me and you can put this on
the top of the tree let me feel
hey I got the top here it's right here
yes right here let's see what are you
doing
you know what just put that on the top
we gonna plug it in on the bottom okay
we'll just don't worry I've given up I
got one of the multiple ports or do they
called you know the surge protector oh
I've got two of them good cuz we're
gonna need it
yeah we could use both of us you got any
more oh oh all right yeah wait wait wait
I still finished my ornament a oh yeah
that's it it's wet hmm it's still wet
let me find me use everything they find
my hook I have glue all over my hands I
ain't feel like I'm a mess Oh what's
wrong well happen I shouldn't let it dry
before okay I think that this is pretty
good how are you feeling I feel
excellent
I feel festive and I feel like I have
mascara Oliver and see what we've done
yeah blindfolded tree decorating
challenge ready one two three
Oh oh no oh god yeah okay he has seen
some home I ordered me a little you
haven't even plugged it in yet we have
to plug it in well this is it the
perfect time to turn on our tree it is
now nighttime the Sun has gone down and
let's turn this thing on let's light it
up girl
oh right okay I'm gonna see those
Christmas light this one
Oh Bernie one more there's another one
here it is ready yeah
the rainbow oh my god it's really good
blindfolded Christmas tree challenge you
know this looks better than my tree when
I decorated it with my eyes open
oh that's unfortunate these actually
look good if you guys want to make a
little DIY like Christmas balls like
just crinkle up some paper and shove it
in this thing I like that thank you I
liked your star that is not yellow paper
I was going to skip it hello this is
really creative okay this is really good
they got a blind blindfolded reindeer or
at a mint that's amazing I'm pretty
impressed it's just pretty much the
ornaments that I made when I was two
years old I mean the lights may be
slightly tangles okay oh yeah but I will
say the back of our tree is also not
naked there's a lot going on over here
yeah I think I kinda lost track of what
was the front of the back of the side so
we were decorating absolutely everything
well guys thanks so much for watching
thank you all for participating in this
I'm so sorry I made a mess in your house
we're gonna do so much fun and serious
vacuuming worth it make sure you guys
get check out rows channel we have done
so many fun videos over there and you
also have so many amazing baking videos
if you guys are fans of like actually
good incredible baking stuff like
anything good that I do is because Roewe
has taught me how well thanks for
hanging out and making a tree have a
holiday you like the holidays now this
does now that we've got a tree let the
holidays are all I'm ready I'm gonna go
just put this in my living room now it's
gonna look great or we could get this to
our favorite youtuber that's true hey
Joey hey Joey or Jordan why did the tree
I don't think Jordan would be that into
this because he isn't like reindeer does
he not like reindeer I don't know where
gingerbread men see I was more concerned
about the glitter and stuff it'll
probably like it'll be a to blame you
know I'm thinking you might like shed
and then I never really no no you have
to vacuum is not gonna lead on he's got
a lot of vacuums though so ya think
you'd be alright alright that's it let's
uh let's go
known for this well sad sounds are good
I'll pick it up at the bottle okay okay
wait gets plugged in though oh oh yeah
yeah my sleeve here gonna enjoy it okay
hi bye you guys happy holidays
[Music]